all entries to the capital secured
police say they're searching for knives
machetes or any illegal weapons that
these provincial passengers may be
carrying on their way to Lima police are
on high alert hours before a nationwide
protest to demand a change of government
we can protest without violence it's our
right in the Constitution
more than 8 000 police are being
deployed on Wednesday to protect Lima
rights groups say their powers to search
are unconstitutional
this is not a harassment it's a
preventative security measure to
guarantee not slam people's rights
took office in December rights groups
have documented the deaths of 49 people
they say were shot by Security Forces
on Tuesday called on demonstrators for
Unity and to merge peacefully the
government has warned it will use
legitimate Force against violence
we don't understand why they will again
announce their arrival waving the flag
of war and trying to take over the
center it's a threat to democracy and we
will not allow or accept this
critics say the government's measures
inflict fear in the population
millions of peruvians are increasingly
frustrated with the government they say
is unable to resolve health and economic
issues many are going to join in the
protest because they say the only way
for president boluarte to go is by
forcing her out
[Applause]
opinion polls say 80 percent of
peruvians want boluarte to resign and 90
want Congress to close elections are in
due for another three years analysts say
the economy is entering a recession
unrest since December has reduced the
GDP by more than one billion dollars
the government is weak it doesn't
connect to the people's demands and with
such a low approval the protest could
deepen the crisis affecting the
government's legitimacy if human rights
are not respected the situation is going
to get more complex that's causing the
government's reaction ahead of the
protests
the government extended a state of
emergency for another month tensions are
high ahead of Wednesday's protests
Mariana Sanchez Lima